welcome back to cbs this morning during
the pandemic we've relied on those hand
sanitizers
to help keep us safe but now an
independent study suggests
some products may be having the exact
opposite effect
researchers detected higher than allowed
levels of benzene and 21 products from
15 different brands
cbs news found some of those products
for sale on major retailers websites
chronic exposure to benzene is known to
cause blood disorders
including leukemia our chief medical
correspondent
dr john lapook joins us to explain john
i was complaining about dry hands it
sounds so good after listening to that
what more do we know
good morning gail the company valuser
says it found elevated levels of benzene
in a small percentage of the 260
products
it tested the leading brand purell and
many others had no detectable levels of
benzene
but for the ones on the list valisture
has petitioned the fda to launch
an investigation and recall
honestly i was shocked i was shocked
that we were finding benzene
at all it might very well be the most
well known compound
that is dangerous to humans david light
runs vallasher
an independent lab and pharmacy that
test drug products for quality
over the last several months they
started finding benzene
a known carcinogen in some hand
sanitizers
balance year's chief scientific officer
corey kuchera walked us through the
testing process
so this peak represents the amount of
benzene that's in this bottle
correct and that's high that's high
in the early days of the pandemic the
fda relaxed standards on benzene levels
in liquid hand sanitizers according to
dr leonardo trasande
there was a an effort to really
increase hand sanitizers and
the availability because a lot of people
were purchasing them and
supply was running low the fda allowed
liquid hand sanitizers to contain
benzene in a concentration of up to two
parts per million
valasyr tested hundreds of products for
benzene that sounds like the bottom line
is
there are a lot of products that pass
that that are okay that's true
but there are a few of them that really
failed
yeah valishare says of 260 products
21 from 15 brands tested above the fda
interim limit
the top three tested between six to
eight times higher than allowed
batches of this sanitizer with a baby
yoda on the front
contain nearly double the allowable
amount attempts to get a response from
manufacturer best brands consumer
products were unsuccessful
cbs news found the product available on
amazon
who told cbs news it is investigating
the products in question
there's no reason for that kind of a
product to be on the market
it just should not be permitted dr
daniel teitelbaum is an expert on
benzene exposure
he warns benzene absorption could be
increased in workers who use a hand
sanitizer contaminated with benzene
then put on gloves that prevent
evaporation
if you're not wearing gloves over them
the risk is quite low because
your skin is warm you use that the
benzene will evaporate quite rapidly
and there are people who have special
risks
it's a lot of healthcare personnel it's
a lot of cleaning and sanitation people
and what about if they continue to use
it say over the years to come
well the longer you use it the greater
the risk
in a statement the walt disney company
said it launched independent testing on
the baby yoda sanitizer
and has instructed best brands to
withdraw the product until more is
learned
if you want to see which products were
flagged by valisher we've shared their
research on cbsnews.com
the fda says they're reviewing dallas
year's petition and continue to test
sanitizer products
and monitor the market so john first
yikes and second if benzene is a known
carcinogen and so well known
how is it ending up in hand sanitizers
in the first place
tony it's not supposed to be there and
dr teitelbaum explained to me that one
possible way it gets there is that
companies need to purchase alcohol for
the hand sanitizer
and they may get it from a place that
manufactures it
from crude oil and that can be a
contaminant benzene can be a contaminant
of the crude oil
processing uh situation so um we're
going to need the fda to look into this
more and hopefully they'll get back with
an answer and a ruling about this sooner
rather than later
all right we've got those products to to
watch on our website john thank you very
much
a reminder you can always get the
morning's news by subscribing to the cbs
this morning podcast you'll hear the
day's top stories
in less than 20 minutes